maybe a bit of a fun question
what three books technical fiction
philosophical
you've enjoyed had a big big impact in
your life
well i guess i go back to like my my
teen years and and uh you know i read
sid arthur which is a philosophical book
and kind of helps keep me keep me
centered
yeah my herman has to exactly don't get
too wrapped up in
material things or other things and just
sort of you know try to find peace
on things um a book that actually
influenced me a lot in terms of my
career was
called the worldly philosophers by uh
robert howe brenner it's actually about
economist it goes through a series of
different companies written in a very
lively form and it probably sounds
boring but it did describe whether it's
adam smith or karl marx or john maynard
keynes
and each of them sort of what their key
insights were but also kind of
their personalities and i think that's
one of the reasons i became an economist
was
was just understanding how they grapple
with the big questions
of the world so would you recommend it
as a good whirlwind
uh overview of the history of economics
yeah yeah i think that's exactly right
it kind of takes you through the
different things um and and you know so
you can understand
how they reach thinking some of the
strengths and weaknesses i mean probably
is a little out of date now it needs to
be updated a bit but
you know you could at least look through
the first couple hundred years of
economics which is not a bad place to
start
uh more recently i mean a book i really
enjoyed is by my uh my friend and
colleague max tag mark called life 3.0
you should have on your podcast if you
haven't already
it was episode number one oh my god
and he's back he'll be back uh he'll be
back soon
yeah no he's terrific i i love the way
his brain works
and he makes you think about profound
things he's got such a joyful approach
to life
and uh so that's been a great book and
you know you learn i learn a lot from it
i think everybody
explains it in a way even though he's so
brilliant that you know everyone can
understand
that i can understand um you know that's
three but let me mention
maybe one or two others i mean i
recently read more from less by
my sometimes co-author andrew mcafee it
made me optimistic about how
we can continue to have rising living
standards
while living more lightly on the planet
in fact because of higher living
standards because of technology because
of digitization that i mentioned
we don't have to have as big an impact
on the planet and that's a great story
to tell and he documents it very
carefully uh
you know a personal kind of self-help
book that i found kind of useful people
is atomic habits
i think it's uh what's his name james
clear yeah james clear um
he's just he has a good name because he
writes very clearly and
you know most of the sentences i read in
that book i was like yeah i know that
but it just really helps to have
somebody like
remind you and tell you and kind of just
reinforce it and
and uh so build habits in your life that
you you hope
to have uh that have a positive impact
and don't have to
make it big things it could be just tiny
little exactly i mean the word atomic
it's a little bit of a pun i think he
says you know one atomic needs are
really small you take these little
things
but also like atomic power it can have
like you know it's big impact
that's funny yeah
you